let's go to your voicemail two one nine
two David P here's another voicemail
asking me about why do I have a problem
with religious financial guy Dave Ramsey
hey David it's birthed me from New
Jersey just want that another day for
empty question I don't understand why I
don't stand the looks like that he's
religious and that he weaves religion
into the vise agus financially but if
that financial advice works I don't see
what's the problem with it whatsoever I
mean you call him mediocre we could call
him basically says he has mediocre
financial advice but yeah it seems to
work pretty well regardless of what it
is especially since ain't no response on
YouTube was you don't take advice really
much how many people so how do you not
like his financial advice if you don't
really have a standing for it or like
that logic doesn't listen just because I
don't take Rick Dave Ramsey's financial
advice doesn't mean I'm not aware of a
lot of the things that he says so a few
things that I disagree with Dave Ramsey
on and I think are bad advice paying off
all debt immediately or as quickly as
possible isn't always the solution
number one number two he often uses a
12% annual return for calculating future
cash flows and the value of investments
no serious financial adviser will tell
you to plan for 12 percent or anything
close to it typically you want to use
the number eight do you want to be
conservative you want to use the number
seven percent for annual growth of
investments he talks about spending
eight percent a year as the safe
withdrawal rate during retirement that's
insanely aggressive historically ninety
percent I'm sorry nine percent of
individuals will get thirty years out of
their money if they withdraw 8% a year
it's way too risky for most retirees
very very bad idea he pushes actively
managed mutual funds absolute disaster
one of the most profitable mechanisms
for the financial industry you want low
cost passively managed funds period
again if he doesn't stand by that
anymore
then maybe I agree with him now he's
recommended financial advisors in the
past I don't want to say their name but
he's recommended advisors from a company
that are paid commissions which is the
worst incentive structure for getting
good financial advice to people period
I've also heard him say in
eliminate all debt before investing
often that's not the right way forward
if you've got a mortgage at 3.5% and you
can get a match on your 401 K from your
employer which can be expected to earn 7
or 8 percent a year over time the
interest on your mortgage is also
tax-deductible why wouldn't you start
investing in the 401k expected to make 7
or 8 percent plus the matching from your
employer which is effectively free money
rather and take the tax deduction on the
mortgage rather than just saving 3.5
percent by paying down the mortgage so
he's filled with bad advice he also
presents it without having to defend it
because some people treat his advice as
again I know he's a religious guy as
gospel so those are a few things about
Dave Ramsey that I don't agree with he's
changed his views let me know we've got
a great bonus show for you today david
pakman.com sorry no join pakman.com is
the new website to sign up